you're so aware
of others feelings
[Music]
what the hell
does some [__] like that
there he is Bob Dole wow look at that
holy mackerel oh man what an honor to
see you sir you're a good day I got my
casual look on here how do you like it
you look fantastic Mr Dolan and you
don't look a day over 85 in person I got
to tell you you look great I've traveled
all around this country and I met the
people of America and I learned one
thing about him what is that I don't
like him they're not great people yeah
they're damn Fool's most of them what
about your age I mean you're older than
everyone isn't that true age will not be
a factor in this election I'll let you
know that right now age will not be a
factor yeah unless I die right okay of
course this is the great Norm McDonald
from Saturday Night Live who does Bob
Dosa and he's made up he's fully made up
as well I can't do Impressions oh man I
love you I can do him and I can do Ed
Sullivan let me see that it's Ed
Sullivan uh teaching a class all right
go ahead okay this is this is Ed
Sullivan all right but he's teaching a
grade four class
uh okay uh class today we have a I can't
do the voice right right
okay class today we have a really big
quiz that's good that is really good
the famous Jeopardy bit yes Jeopardy
well you play Burt Reynolds that thing
was one of the most popular sketches and
you pitched the Jeopardy thing the
reason I really did it is I wanted it to
but Reynolds now Lauren Michaels when it
came time to do the sketch I went down I
saw my wardrobe and you know there was a
white beard and a ball the white cabin I
went no no I wanted to do Burt Reynolds
from 1972 right and uh it's funny to me
that but no one ever mentioned it nobody
no one ever mentioned that one guy on
Celebrity Jeopardy is from 40 years
it didn't even matter it didn't occur to
anyone who had Burt Reynolds though
which was an amazing was she pissed
because he doesn't have a big sense of
humor does he no he was real nice to me
and he told me really funny stories he
told me he was in the Deliverance you
know which I yeah you know he said uh
you know I used to do my own gags gags I
I guess are like uh stunts he was a
stunt man yeah and so he said uh you
know they had this gag where I went over
a waterfall so he says I'll do the file
we don't need a we don't need to stop
man frankenheimer says no no we need to
stop man he goes nah we don't want that
you know yeah frankenheimer says okay
well we'll just use a dummy we'll just
throw a dummy over and he goes no no so
frankenheimer's idea was just to throw a
dummy over and then Birdman said no
absolutely I'm gonna do it myself so
Brent Brown says he does it he said his
uh shoulder immediately hit a rock then
his head hit another rock and then he
said the next thing he remember is way
Downstream all his clothes had been torn
off and I mean you [__] up and it was
just like in shock right the next thing
he remembers he's waking up in a
hospital John frankenheimer is at his
bedside and uh he goes now I said to
John uh how'd it look you know on the uh
on the daily and John frankenheimer said
it looked like a dummy falling out there
you are the uh Shining Light on Saturday
Night Live the best part of Saturday
Night Live is when you do the news right
so why did they fire you how did they
fire you how do they tell you they're
firing you tell me everything well it
was like over the holidays
um
it was what holiday was that the
Christmas oh okay go ahead all right
just be clear over the Christmas
holidays yeah I started hearing stuff
about hey it don't look good and things
they want to make changes and I didn't
know what they were attacking who was
telling you this this different people
at Saturday Night Live you know you had
heard rumors that there were going to be
changes it doesn't look good and so then
uh I was hanging out and stuff and then
the guys go hey man you gotta call this
dude Don Omar is the president of uh the
network Donald Myers the president of
NBC right and they're telling you you've
got a call Don Omar right so when you
call Don Omar what did he say he said he
didn't want me to do uh update why
um because uh
um he doesn't think I was funny he said
that to your face yeah I don't think
you're funny when he did this he said to
me that that update is like dragging
down the show and that really that yeah
gee I must not know anything well and
then what did you do did you yell at him
did you say anything to him or did you
just hang up no I just said uh listen uh
uh you know if I'm unfunny that he said
you know I wanted to you know I want you
to be better and I go I can't because if
I'm not funny how can I make myself
funny I'm not a funny guy can't be funny
who will be the news guy now on Saturday
Night Live I think maybe it's Colin
that's what it says in the newspaper
yeah and it says you agreed to be
replaced well that sure is Alex that's
not true you love doing the Weekend
Update sure and be serious yeah that's
the thing I like doing the best that's
the only thing I like doing I know I
love you doing it and you're accepting
this
I know you now with Saturday Night Live
in any other capacity or if you quit no
I gotta keep doing sketches is that
right and you don't want to do sketches
sometimes they write in sketches and
this is what they didn't do when I was
on update because I had update yeah but
all of a sudden you got to be like uh
you know you got to be like the
scientists that discovered monkey boy or
something I know I know yeah you're the
scientists are discovered you're being a
straight romantic monkey boy I'm with
you on this Don Omar is a good man
though I mean man don't kiss the
corporate ass that just fired you yeah
it just seems like he's stuck by his uh
his OJ you know he's stuck by his friend
there you go Don Omar she got stuck by
O.J this is a really good way of saying
he's a good guy oh he's a good you are
an amazingly calculated man oh man
you don't meet this guy Milos Foreman
yeah he's a big director so he signed me
on Saturday Night Live so he got the
idea I was smart
everybody
[Music]
so it's me him and two guys from Fort to
foreigners right and so these guys know
everything you know and uh so they're
like ah what about the situation and the
Balkans or something yeah you're the
news man and I just kind of play along
like by repeating what they'd said three
sentences and uh so anyways he goes I
put you in the movie man I need a guy to
and he was gonna give me a big purse
right so I was like no no no don't do
that
and he's like I don't worry about it I
go seriously milosh I don't want you to
give me a big part of you what do you
want I go just you know give me a small
part that'd be cool so he made me a
reporter right in this in this people
versus Larry Flynt right yes yeah I
played one of the people right so
originally I think it sounds like you
were about to be Larry Flynn right oh my
God damn Larry Flynn so we uh go to uh
we do the movie right and uh and I'm a
reporter you know so he goes you know
you drive up and get out of the car and
run in I go well I can't drive
look at a cab will drive you so it
doesn't make sense like a reporter is in
a cab so we do the scene it's me and
Larry Flynt you know and me and Woody
Harrelson yeah so then anyways uh Woody
Harrelson is really cool and [__]
actors man when they're really good it's
like something different right you know
because I'm just I'm just waiting for
the other [__] to stop talking about I
remember you're not even paying
attention no I'm just hoping to remember
my words so anyways uh [__] what's
his name Woody Harrelson asked me if I
wanted beer you know he goes uh you want
a beer I go no that's cool
I don't I don't drink you know he goes
you don't want a beer I go no I don't
drink but thanks man and then I go uh
you drink like uh I thought you just
smoke weed and all that [__] and then uh
all of a sudden Milo schwerman goes cats
what the [__] is going on like we were
in the movie you didn't know yeah
and talking like a regular person there
was nothing fake about it
you went to do some college show yeah
and you go out there and they say you're
so drunk you can't get through the show
yeah wow is that true I believe that
yeah
it doesn't make any sense no I I don't
drink very much you don't drink at all
no hardly ever so what happens well a
lot of times people like on stage will
think that I'm drunk like I often get
that right people go hey man you're
wasted you're like Cheech and Chong they
weren't really high they just acted like
they were high I think one of them was
which one everybody into college where I
went everybody was drunk like they were
all drinking beer in a beer tent since
noon what were you talking about that
night I was talking about them being
drunk he said hey you guys are all
drunks yeah sometimes like you say to a
drunk guy that he's drunk and he gets
mad belligerent and there's no you're
drunk yeah so it's like that they they
hated me and then they started throwing
stuff out yeah and then I didn't want to
leave because I didn't want to not get
paid right so you stayed on the full
hour well I stayed on until they finally
came up and said no you can go but yeah
it was that painful everyone's just
screaming at you right the entire time
and then like the girl from the college
would call me over and I go what what do
you want she'd go do those jokes like
you do on Letterman yeah yeah I have a
college girl telling you what to do
because people are just screaming like
obscenities you can't go were they
throwing things at you they're throwing
things so you can't do an act you can't
go like does anyone have an answering
machine do you ever do a show where it's
successful or is it always easy it goes
really good really it's kind of funny
when like they hate you because all
you're trying to do is make them laugh
it's funny yeah and this one guy when
he's walking out he said I am going to
kill you
any guy goes hey you know I think he's
going to tell me like Sam he's the
security guy and he goes why don't you
try to be funny he's like the security
guy yeah well it's not so easy
in Florida where I just was they have
people that if I don't know what the
[__] they do but everybody got money so
a guy picks me up he's a limo driver and
he's like
he goes I [__] I can take you any
place man anything you want I go what
yes
on because I got my wife and I got your
wife like I thought he was talking about
like drugs or something he starts with
his wife he could take you to his wife
since I can get anything I want and then
he goes my wife
was he offering you his wife
but it wasn't it was all weekend long I
just meet four or five guys and I go Hey
so uh this is the wife and this is the
other wife and
how about the eight of us oh yeah
to say it right out but you kind of go
ah what are you talking about
they don't really know what the [__]
going on because they don't come right
out and say they want to [__] you things
were going really well in the fantasy
you Nancy and Shirley and suddenly Earl
walked in yeah what the [__] you never
told me and then they're like well if we
brought it up we thought you'd say no of
course I [__] say no you could live
in a hot climate there's not a whole lot
to do you rely on other people and it
becomes like an orgy State nobody told
me about a guy coming out of a closet
whacking off with his half-hard [__]
girl was an afterthought I'm not a fancy
guy Fred you know that really I always
thought of he was a fan my thing is like
for sexual encounters I mean I like to
lie on top of a lady
hey Norm are you married or not would
you clear that up what are you married
yeah absolutely but you don't like
people to know that it's bad for your
image no I don't want you know I've had
like a stock or something oh you have
had stalkers I would be afraid of
somebody who would stop yeah this one
guy right that's a scary person in New
York who's all stalking me and it was my
own fault because I was like and then
I'm on the street yeah and I was trying
out women yeah what I'm an idiot you
hung out with the guy a little bit and
then what happened uh well he was just
this dude I was walking down and I was
like I I had a coughing I was coughing
on the street and then like five blocks
later he's right beside me with a glass
of water right he goes hey man I got
some water was it in a bottle or was it
open like an overtime and you drank it I
know I didn't know what it was really
what happened well uh he was uh I was
phoning me I gave my phone number why
did you give him your phone number
yeah so so anyways uh six months pass
I'm in Los Angeles and I'm walking down
the street and that dude is there oh my
God so we're standing there and then in
L.A like there's no pedestrian so you're
all alone yeah I mean there's no
protection yeah so I'm just standing
with this guy did he have water with him
he goes hey I just want you to know I'd
do anything for you
and then we were standing in front
there's this restaurant in uh in L.A
called Norms yeah restaurants right I'm
talking to this guy and he goes look
behind you and I look and there's this
big sign Norms yeah and so I go yeah he
goes Norms right like he thought there's
a message yeah yeah so I said no I just
live here I'm trying to tell them it's
like a coincidence
actually I went to the hospital because
uh I go to the hospital a lot but uh
what are you doing there man well I'm
just kind of like I worry about stuff
right but what happened was uh Dennis
Rodman was on the show you know that guy
yeah sure so would that be funny if he
head-butted me you know right so uh he
tells me I you know if I go don't really
head butt me you know yeah you're like a
professional athlete you're like one of
the strongest guys and I'm like one of
the weakest guys so don't do that so he
says no I won't you know I know what I'm
doing I'll just put my thumbs up and
like when I touch my thumbs you push
back and then when he does it he head
butts me like really hard wow and I like
blanked after I didn't see any thumbs
yeah he cracked did you actually did you
blank out yeah blanked out for like 10
seconds oh because I don't get that
whole headbutt thing man that hurts so I
went to the hot like I had a headache
for like two days wow yeah are you like
a hypochondriac like me like do you
think anything happened yeah right so I
go to the hospital I thought I was gonna
die and stuff and I go out of my head
and so then you know you get to the
hospital late at night it's all like
crack addicts you gotta wait a long time
with just a headache yeah excuse me I
got head-butted yeah get in line they
didn't believe me that was nuts they
thought it was I think everybody's on
drugs yeah right they thought you were
hallucinating yeah I said I said Dennis
Rodman head-butted me
don't you do Ed Sullivan
yeah you don't like a guy with a sticky
joke after joke after joke there's very
few that I like but I love Rodney
Dangerfield is my favorite I met Rodney
man when I was [__] I made the worst
mistake ever which I was in the [__]
hotel and I loved running [__] and I was
coming down in the in the casino I was
coming down the [__] elevator and
Rodney was in the elevator I'm like oh
my God it's Rodney I gotta say something
to him so anyways I'd worked on some
stupid [__] thing with this director
yeah who said he worked with Rodney yeah
so I used that as a thing right so I go
hey Rodney I go we have a common friend
he goes who's that I go you know Paul
Johnson he goes that [__] because
that fucker's no friend and there's a
full elevator because that [__] is no
friend of mine you tell him he can suck
my dick I'm like oh I'm not his friend
I'm not his friend I've met him I was on
Saturday Night Live because he came in
when I did update so we have to do dress
first at 8 30 and then at 11 30 of the
show you know right he goes listen man
he goes what the [__] man why am I doing
it at 8 30. you know it's a sad thing I
know my [__] joke folks I'll just
come back at 11 30. I go I don't know
how it works right you got to do it he
goes God damn he goes let me tell you
something kid this was a device man he
goes this [__] TV [__] you know he
goes just waiting around all the [__]
time it's a bunch of so [__] you know
it's [__] because it's the same with
[__] movies you know you're in the
movie and then you're in the [__]
trailer all the time that's all you're
doing is [__] jerking off in the
trailer you know he goes it's all [__]
kid he goes remember this and remember
it forever stand up man that's all there
is stand up and he meant it then there's
a [__] like five minute pause you
look at me right in the eyes you go
stand up [__] he forgot it's all [__]
Farley was out of his mind even off
camera right you joined Saturday Night
Live they send you to the Catskills to
have some sort of bonding weekend for
the new cast and Farley comes running in
naked naked into your room yes Farley
comes right and he had a tomato shoved
up his ass he had uh he said would you
like to see my impression of a salad and
he poured a salad dressing all over his
head and started shoving baby Tomatoes
up his ass wow and did you think this
guy is the greatest or did you think
what the [__] is that it was the
funniest thing I ever saw and then he
took me and he said I have to tell you a
secret you know and I was so like I was
saying oh my God the great Farley has to
tell me a secret you know something
about Saturday Night Live that I should
know and that was a big big Resort and
he finally found a room you know that
was any on purpose looking back on now
he took all this time to finally find a
room and he locked the door and he
brought me in the corner and he said
this goes nowhere okay you know this is
between you and I Pat is a woman
you see I'm interested in that you know
I laughed so hard that he would do this
for a stranger you know and that's why I
love Farley so much and he's so much
different than all the rest of us is
that he would go down the street and uh
and just perform for everybody and I'm
telling you everybody loved Chris Farley
the young the old the the smart that's
what they say the stupid the people that
liked him the people that hated him yeah
you know we had a guy come in and do a
bad review on the show about how
horrible it was and how horrible Farley
was and you know he laughed everything
Farley said
Jack Warden when he first came into the
the Dirty Work I was sitting there with
the producer in The Saga or whatever
right he came in and he was like hey how
are you guys doing you know he goes Hey
listen I'm excited to meet this Norm
Macdonald kid and I was sitting there I
was very embarrassed right right he goes
I'm very excited to meet this kid I'm a
big fan of his you know uh when's he
gonna so it's really humiliating you
know okay I had to say who I was you
know she goes when's he gonna come
around when am I going to meet him I got
you yeah
forget his lines and it was driving him
crazy you know right and the director of
these [__] television directors they
go over to him and they'd Go Jack you're
doing fine he goes don't [__] me
dude oh you [__] [__]
and then I'd have to remember everything
just in case he remembered the one scene
you know yeah there's pressure on you
yeah imagine you don't remember I don't
remember anything anyway so I'd have to
make sure I remember it so I remember
the scene whereas we're watching a
hockey game you know and uh Jack
warden's supposed to go he's playing an
old tough guy you know and he goes so
his first line is no I'm hockey is not
the same as it used to be you know it's
the helmets you know when I was a kid
they were tough you know so that was his
opening line you know so he started the
scene he looks at me he just blank in
his eyes I know he doesn't remember
anything but he's a good enough actor he
thinks he can fake it you know right so
he looks at him he goes there's nothing
then he goes Nami Mommy
I know he's looking now he's trying to
pressure he goes
I mean and now it's Hocking on me
hockey he goes it's different nowadays
Nami uh it sounds different with the
hockey yeah no I mean it's different
difference the helmet's not me the
helmets you know wow he's a disaster
I read on the computer that Gilbert said
something back at Aflac or something
well I don't you know Gilbert is not the
type to apologize for anything he says
but I think it costs them a lot of money
the Affleck gig was easy once a year he
goes in he acts like a duck and he makes
a ton of donuts he doesn't even have to
say anything but Aflac all right
so I can add I did an audition for it
did you did you it seems like everyone
is being auditioned dude did you try to
sound like Gilbert or did you try to
yeah they said I wouldn't I have only
been on like five auditions in my life
and everyone's been a [__] nightmare
you don't strike me as an auditioning
kind of guy the worst [__] ever so I
go in and then the woman goes like I go
I just thought I have to say Aflac once
right that's easy so she goes listen
um create I want you to create a story
like that's what I want you to do like
when you just think of the deck be
quizzical and funny and then uh
sarcastic and then serious and then sexy
and she goes just create a story have
fun they all say [__] have fun with
it no this is my work but if it's not
fun here so then like three seconds in
I'm like I want to get the [__] out of
here
so she left and then there's this me and
a guy with a hat so I said listen man
let me just I'll just say Aflac and get
the [__] out of here because uh you know
I only got so many [__] moments in my
life right and I've got a Life to Live
yeah so it's me a guy with a hat he's
telling me how to say Aflac I'm saying
Affleck I'm going I gotta [__] I
don't have that many years left it
dawned on you that this is an actual
like if a doctor told you had three
weeks to live you'd say God I'm spending
too much time being here exactly it was
such a genuine moment when you were the
last stand-up comic to perform on Dave's
show sometimes with the way you are the
way you carry yourself I don't see you
as an overly emotional person and I was
really moved honestly when you were the
last Comic to perform on Letterman you
went out and did a set and then you
turned to Dave and you said a couple of
heartfelt things and and you were moved
to tears and I was really moved by that
because I didn't know you felt that way
about Letterman and you were so
complementary to him and you kind of let
down the the comedy thing which I
thought was so strong because when
you're doing stand-up you know you it's
false by Nature yes and then all of a
sudden you kind of opened up as to who
you were for real yeah and you showed
Letterman how much you cared about him
I'd just like to say I know that uh Mr
Letterman is uh uh not for the Marcus
and uh he has uh he has no truck for the
sentimental but if something is true it
is not sentimental and I say unsure I
love you
oh and it was really genuinely moving
and I think it's because you feel like
wow well also it was accidental I didn't
go out there with that plan no but you
wanted to say something I wanted to say
something I didn't know quite it was it
wasn't that right
um it was some stupid thing I'd written
you know that sounded just written and
fake and then when I started to say it I
was like I was gonna say it I'll just
talk you know did Letterman say anything
to you afterwards after the show was
over or was there was no discussion of
it he whispered in my ear or something
but you want to keep private just keep
private as much as Saturday Night Live
holds memories for me and David
Letterman although I have no backstage
uh experience with them at all right
just the things he's talked to me about
in between
commercials and stuff like that I I
always felt so uh so close I felt I
really felt like um
the the type of Father figures that he
was my father figure
hey you want to hear a joke from Mac
yeah it's about that whatever happens in
Vegas stays in Vegas I heard that so
actually it done really stated like you
can't it's not even kill a person and
then leave Vegas and as everything's
cool you know right so I what I did was
I looked at that phrase what it actually
means is basically you can go to Vegas
[__] a prostitute and then she will not
tell your wife
that's exactly exactly what they're
saying
you're saying not like those gossipy
small town [__]
you're saying where you come from I'm
saying that back at home their their
blabber Mouse you're saying they're
sitting in the beauty parlor going oh
you're married to Hank Johnson I [__]
[__] on his face last time all right
listen we're having too much fun with
Norm we can talk to him all day yeah I
could go with you all day you're easy
all right get some stiff signing it
sometimes they don't have anything to
say no
is good
McDonald everyone
great nor McDonald Norm you are a genius
foreign